right now I'm very focused on this thing
we call pack platforms and culture we
believe the way to win in Social is to
be great at understanding the platforms
the algorithms the features what filters
work is it a real over in feed when are
you able to do on them and then the
culture what's happening in pop culture
who are the most interesting musicians
what meals are emerging what restaurants
what regions in America is fishing
culture doing this you know what the
summer Anthem going to be if you do
those two things extremely well the
output of the creative you do in Social
can be affected by that if you do that
well the consumer insights both Quant
and qual that you can get out of that
kind of work really can feed your above
the line and brand building